(speaking in English)
- [Interpreter 1] Very well, good morning.
Welcome to
Bedicheck High School.  I
am the...
Let's talk about
consolidation and TAP.
So, thank you for
being here this morning
and being part of this conversation
and having this space to ask questions
about what's happening
with the Bedicheck community.
And thank you for being here.
And without further ado,
I will introduce our
superintendent, Segura,
and begin.
Oh, sorry, let's do it this way first.
Good morning.  I'll
start by talking about the agenda
and what we can expect.  My
name is Ali Ghilarducci,
I am the executive director
of communications
and community engagement.
We're going to talk about the
purpose of this meeting
and introduce some of
the people who are here.
And then we're going to do a summary
of the changes proposed
specifically for here.
And if you recall,
we have a new version of the plan.
So, right now we are
still working on
that next version.
So, we've also
read many of your questions
on your comment cards.
And we have prepared some
answers for them.
And if you have any further comments, we'd be happy to hear them; there
will be plenty of time
for questions and comments
after that.
So, for the board's rules,
we want to build the future together.
We want to acknowledge the
difficulties of the current situation
and focus on ideas and solutions.
We want to respect the time.
So, we're going to ask you to
speak for about a minute
to give others a chance
to speak too.
We want to talk to each other,
not against each other, to be respectful.
(speaking in English)
And we want to try to respect the order
in which we are speaking.
We want to respect the agenda,
and we want to respect the
intention and the impact.
We may disagree
about the ideas,
but we assume a positive intention
and a focus on having strong schools
for all students.  We
will also respect
space and voices.
If you've already spoken once,
please let
others speak too.
And we're going to stay
solution-oriented.
We want to think about what is needed
to solve the problems
instead of focusing
on our frustration so that
we can succeed.
And finally,
we want to be transparent and empathetic.
We want to be honest and as
transparent as possible.
So, if you ask a question
and feel we didn't answer it,
please let us know.
We want to make sure
that your answers,
your questions, get answers.
The purpose of
today's meeting is to answer the questions you
have submitted through
the comment cards.  To
reach a
common understanding of the reasons
that justify the proposed changes.
And we want to obtain information that contributes
to possible solutions.
And now the superintendent is coming.
If you can, please
stay here because
we are recording this meeting
in English and Spanish.
Thanks, Ali.
Yes, don't go too far over there.
I appreciate you all coming
this morning
and having this
conversation about the plan
and all things related
to Bedicheck.
Before we begin those
questions and answers,
I want us to have a conversation
about why we are
doing this work
and why we are doing it now.
One of the things we've been talking about
as a school district, as an administration,
for the past two years,
is that we need to ensure
that all of our students
have everything they need
to succeed.
But there are also many other things
required for
academic success.
We need to make sure we
have services,
programs, and alignment.
The reality is that in Austin ISD
there are very strong neighborhood schools,
but there are also schools
where families choose to
leave that neighborhood
and choose another school.
And if we think about where we are now,
there is a lot of pressure on us.
The first is that the state,
the state of Texas, the
governor really,
has made it really difficult for us to get
the resources we need.
Second, we have to recognize
that the
accountability system has changed.
And if we don't respond to him,
we could risk him
taking control of Austin ISD.
The board is here
to give direction to the school district
and we want to make sure that
continues.
The other thing I want to say
is that in recent years they
have seen that enrollment
in the ISD has decreased.
And there are things that have contributed to that,
but the city has changed.
During all these
years that
the school district has been here,
students have moved
and adjustments have to be made.
So, all these things
have put a lot of pressure
on our school system.
So, if we want to
have solid schools,
strong schools,
then we have to do something
comprehensive, something holistic.
And there are several elements.
The first is that we need to make sure we have
aligned referral patterns.
That means that one
has a primary school
that goes to no more than two secondary schools
and that one secondary school does not go
to more than two high schools.  You
can imagine that
this exists in Austin right now.
No, not in East Austin,
not in Downtown Austin.
We have schools
that go to three, four,
five high schools.
So, think about the complexity
and misalignment
and how we separate families.
So, we want to
make sure that the boundaries
of school attendance zones
are aligned.
Second, we wanted to
address the difficulties
regarding the transfer process.
There are rules that exist that have
led to certain results
that, I don't know, were not what we wanted.
So, we want to understand
if we need to make adjustments
so that in the future
these transfers can be made
without creating an imbalance in the system.
And three, we have too many
empty seats in Austin ISD,
even with adjustments, capacity,
and all the needs, we
still have 20,000 empty seats.
So, to put that in context,
three thousand more than at the Moody Center.
Three thousand more than the seats
at the Moody Center.
So, what happens
is that when we have so
many empty places,
it becomes very expensive because of
the way we support
our school system.
And the only way to reduce our costs
is to consolidate, right?
In 1996, we had approximately
73,000 students
and 96 schools.
Now in 2025,
we have 70,000 students and 116 schools.
So, we can see that
we have grown in certain areas
and shrunk in certain areas.
And unless we put everything online, we
won't be able to ensure
student success.
And the other thing I want to talk about
is the accountability system.
We need to be very honest
about our schools
and acknowledge that as a school district we
have not ensured
that our students
in schools
have what they need to succeed.  It is
not the fault of the
students or the families.
It is a series of decisions
or lack of decisions
during the last few years
and more the pressure from the state
that has put us in this situation
of having to respond to those risks.
When you have
unacceptable responsibility ratings,
and given the amount we have,
if we don't handle that properly,
if we don't support those students
to make sure they get to
where they need to get, it's going to
be very difficult
for the school district.
So, the last thing I want to say
is that we also wanted to ensure
that the programs are aligned.
There have been programs and
those programs have been supported,
but over time,
the students who should
be the focus of those programs
have changed or moved away.
So, for example, we have
dual language programs
throughout the school
in schools where
the student population
that should be the emerging bilinguals
and who should be the
focus of that program are becoming fewer and fewer
because they
no longer live in those areas.
So, we want to
stabilize those programs,
and that's why we need to move them
to where those people have access.  I do
n't know what happened here,
but I'm going to move on to the next slide.
So, the next one, yes.
(speaking in English)
We have discussed that
we want to close Bedicheck
and then come back, maybe
reopen it in the future.
And the board members
have been talking to them
about what the timeline would look like.
(speaking in English)
During the closure,
we have to assign a
transformation plan
to the Bedicheck school.
And the way that happens is,
which school will receive the
majority of the students
and based on where
Bedicheck is located.
Covington is going to receive the majority.
And so, the changes that have been made
between the first plan and this new plan
are that Lively has been removed from the list
of receiving schools.
And that was to avoid having so many
divisions in this area.
So, we wanted to
limit disruptions.
The other thing I wanted to say
in the next slide.
Yes, we are...
I want to be very clear.
I recognize how important
Bedicheck High School is
to South Austin.
To be honest, I
grew up in South Austin.  It
is a very,
very important school campus for the ISD.
But the reality is that I have to take action,
that I have to make changes
in order to evolve
as a school district.
The board and I have talked
about re-visualizing
what Bedicheck is going to be
through a series of transitions.
So, one of the things I
want to be very clear about
is that I cannot start
school again,
the school year, the
next school year.
There needs to be time, there needs to be
planning.
So, one of the things we
're working on right now
is making sure the plan is well-defined enough so
that you
can all hold me and the board members responsible
and acknowledge that there are
things that aren't here,
that we're going to have to talk
to the staff and the students about.
- [Interpreter 2] Then,
we'll talk about that.
(speaking in English)
So, I can't give much certainty.
So, because we need to
see the process.
(speaking in English)
There is a demonstration.
We can continue, but only once we
arrive.
Let's take a break.
(speaking in English)
So, we are making
a lot of changes
to our
transfer procedures,
to our approach.
One thing that wasn't clear
from our first plan
is that if you're a
transfer student at Bedicheck, you'll
automatically be approved
to go to one of the
schools you choose.
So, if you transfer
from outside the district,
let's say you're in Kyle
and you're coming to Bedicheck,
and most of your friends and
family are going to Covington, we would
automatically
approve you to go here, there.  I do
n't want families to be disrupted.
This is already too disruptive in itself.
So, many of the
students who go to Paredes,
and this child who wants to go to
Paredes, we will do it too.
So, I want to be clear about
any changes we make.
The other thing we've
changed is that if you're a
sixth or ninth grade student,
if you were in fifth
grade the whole time
and you always thought you were going to
go to this middle school,
or you're in eighth grade
and you were thinking of going to a
specific ninth grade school,
we're going to approve all of those transfers
and we won't have
school limits.  We're going
to assure you that
we're planning
to keep those students if
a transfer is approved.  We've
already seen the numbers, we can do it,
and with time we'll have to
achieve a balance
and a strategy.
So, let's make sure
we have something specific
so we can identify something.
(speaking in English)
So, here's the plan.
Thank you.
(speaking in English) Speak up
.
So, we can say it's
a small change.
(speaking in English)
So...
So, we could have
a portion that you see,
it's a small portion.
Turn up the volume.
(speaking in English)
So, we're going to be able to do it (indistinctly).
So, as you can see here,
so that the screen,
the speaker doesn't bother me.
So, this is one
of the limits for Bedicheck currently,
and this is the new limit
so that, it's in blue,
they would be zoned for Paredes.
If they live in the green area,
they would be zoned for Covington.
And if they are in the blue-purple area,
they would be zoned for the other school.
This is number one for Lively,
and it changed so that he could make other divisions
and keep
students as close as possible
to where they want to be.
These are the limits.
So...
This is the last part about
the transformation plan.
Then, we'll be talking
about this whole transformation plan.
It's something we've already
shared before.
So,
any school that requires
the transformation plan
will follow the majority
of students
from the original schools.
Most of the students are
going to Covington.
So, the transformation plan
will follow them to Covington, and that plan
will come with the new
Covington and Bedicheck mix area.
So, once we
have approval
for our entire plan,
we're going to work with that school community
to ensure that the plan
reflects the new goal
of the combined school.
So, anyone being
consolidated into
either the transformation plan or
a rebuild
will be approved by our
superintendent in December
as soon as possible after the vote
so we can make sure we can
start
recruiting staff
and work with
management to get started.
And the sooner we can find that out,
the sooner we'll be
able to control the anxiety
and other feelings of
instability we have.
So, this is how we have this
transformation plan.  He will be
asked
if he has the requirements to be
able to stay at that school.
If they don't have requirements,
there will be a later hiring period
and we'll see which schools
have availability.
And then, there will be a
couple of rounds of this,
and if they want to, and if they want to
stay with us,
that's going to be an option
they can handle.
The other part of the transformation plan
is, as we're talking,
unless there are more,
the more resources are used
for our reconstruction, the more we
can continue to use them.
So, we will receive
$800,000 in funding
for the
school leadership team,
and that can be for transformation.
So, however they need it
, make sure it's important
to meet the goals
of the transformation plan.
And that was the last thing we had.
We have the questions from
the comment cards.
So, we want to start
with the questions here.
I think there are a couple of questions here.
So, what we have is, we've
received a lot of feedback
and then we asked some questions
based on the feedback, but,
so we're happy to be back.
This is your time,
answer their questions.
We have a
conversation to support them.
Yes, ma'am?
(speaking in English)
Then, we can use the microphone
to capture it on video.
(speaking in English)
I am the president of the PTA
of St. Elmo Primary.
Excuse my voice.
We are a school that comes here
and we are divided
between Mendez and Covington.
(speaking in English)
Now I'm going to have, I appreciate all the work
that these
new school boundaries are doing
which have been very complicated,
but the changes we just
saw on the map.
So, we're a
very small part of St. Elmo
on the other side of I-35.
(speaking in English)
This is one of the school boundaries
that AISD said it was going to respect,
and now they're crossing the
lines, and I don't know why.
So, those were
established in the last plan
and some go towards Covington
and now it's Bedicheck.
Apart from that,
(speaking in English)
Mendez is a
charter-run school.
It's right?
Currently, yes.
(speaking in English)
So, they don't have teachers...
So, they don't have
teachers hired from...
So, my tax dollars,
your tax dollars
are going to Austin.
So why are they being
given to the charter school?
(applause)
(speaking in English)
I don't want to...
So, everything he said
is accurate, it's correct.
One of the things I'm going to tell you is that
this plan is forward-looking, it's for the future.
So, yes, there has historically been
an agreement with the schools
that are going to Mendez, and
we will go into this conversation
through this.
I am hyper aware
that ALC is there.  I do
n't know about you, but we're
having conversations
about the spaces and more ideas,
and with a working session
that involves voting,
changes to be able to create
the space in Mendez
to return to what it was.  It's going to
be an Austin ISD school.
The future was never meant to be
a charter forever and take it away.  They're
doing the work there.
We will recover it.
The thing is, what is
this going to look like, and how do we ensure
that all our
students are welcome
and that it truly is an
Austin ISD school? It's also about
hiring the right staff
and making sure we don't
introduce any additional risk.  We've
already taken on new resources, it
requires planning and
we're working on that.
Therefore, everything he said
is accurate and correct.
We're working on
that.  I am aware.
It's one of those things
we did based on
our work session
and it's something we're
working on now.
(speaking in English)
So, currently,
when students are assigned to a school, they will
automatically be approved.
So, families have the option
of going to one of those schools.
So, they're going to give those options
to all families.
So, now I'm going to
go to the first question
on the comment cards.
So, this.
How can the
Austin Independent School District
ensure that this closure does not disproportionately penalize
the Bedicheck student population,
which is an
excessively
disadvantaged segment of the district?
Yes. So,
(speaking in English)
when we look at the impact, we always look at
which students are
going to be affected
and we're going to make sure they're the
closest to this work.
And I'm going to tell you, it really matters,
that we're here, to be very
transparent and see ways
in which schools are being
planned.
So, that's what has to happen.
If we wait until spring
and hope that all these
changes will happen before we prepare,
it will have an adverse impact
on all students.
And so, that's going to be something
that's going to be in our plan.
So, what services do we have?
How are we going to do this effectively?
So, that's really
the main point of our plans.
So, as is our nature,
we have to take the lead,
listen to the student voices,
the voices of the community,
and see how we develop
new plans.
Now the students arrived.
The students arrived.
Good morning!
(applause)
Now, did you have anything you wanted to share?
Anything for the superintendent?
(speaking in English)
If you have a question,
just raise your hand.  Do
you have a piece of paper in your hand?
Is this something you prepared?
Thank you all for.  This
is very important.
It is important to listen to what
ideas, what concerns,
what is going on in your mind.
You are the reason why
we exist.
We are here to support
the students.
This is the only reason
Austin ISD exists.
I know it's tough right now
and there are a lot of things
going through your mind right now,
but please let us know,
tell us how we can support you.
This is tough.
And I know that this has
different kinds of feelings.  They
should let us know what (indistinct).
So, whatever you
have, share it.
If you have any questions,
we can stay
later and talk.
(speaking in English)
Then, you can come.
(giggles)
Yes, you can,
why is the school closing?
(speaking in English) I
have to do it
because there are four very important things happening
that are impacting Bedicheck.
One is that there are not enough students to
fill the south side, who
live in South Austin
between Covington, Paredes,
Lively, and Bedicheck.
And then, when we think about what it takes to
support all our students
when we have small schools, it
makes us very inefficient,
which is very expensive.
And what we know is that
as the numbers have gone down,
that is, there are fewer and fewer students
because it's a bit expensive to live here.
We have to make a decision
because I can't guarantee
that each of you
has what it takes to be successful.  They
need teachers,
they need to have their teachers,
we have to have programs,
we have to,
after-school activities
require resources, money and other things.
And unless I can
find ways to operate
in a
less costly manner, I cannot
guarantee that you will have
everything you have in your
Austin ISD career.
So that's why
we have to
make that decision.  That's why
.
- [Interpreter 1] Thank you.  What's your name?
Rosabela.
To what degree?
Excellent.
Where are you going next year?
Perhaps Crockett.
Oh, I love Crockett.
Crockett is amazing.
(applause)
Excellent work!
Any questions?
What's going to happen to our
EGT geometry class?
The question was, what about GT Einstein?
My job is to make sure we
have programs
to support you.
So, we have
amazing programs at Bedicheck,
and in that transition process,
we're going to determine what
each of you needs
at the other schools and
make sure we have the resources,
the people, and the
programs that are needed
to be in those schools
and welcome you.
Right now, I'm going to be honest,
some schools have
different programs than others,
but it's always based on the
needs of the students.
So, based on what you've taken
and where you want to go,
and your desires and opportunities
that you want to see in the other schools,
we, as a
school district, make that decision.
Programs can be moved.
We move programs all the time.
So, I want it to be there for you.
That program will continue for you.
Excellent question.  What grade are you in?
Eighth?  Are they
all in eighth grade?
No.
Seventh, okay.
Where are you going next year?
Akins.
Okay, excellent.  Thank you for your question.
(applause)
We are doing a question and answer session
with the superintendent.
Two students had questions
and now new students have entered.
This is your opportunity.
If you want to share your ideas
or if you have any questions
for the superintendent, we
can always go back
to the students.
If the students are
thinking about their questions,
they can raise their hand
and we'll come back to them.
Hello, my name is Stephanie Mata.
I have a son in seventh
grade and one in eighth grade.
And my question is
(speaking in English)
why did they renovate the main office
if they were planning to close?
When we started
planning the renovations,
that was in 2021-2022, it was
with that bonus.
(speaking in English)
If there are staff and
students in the building,
we will support them.
But in 2021 and 2022, we were
told that the state was
not going to provide
funding to the schools.
If I had known that,
and that two years later they were
only going to give us so little money,
I wouldn't have believed it, right?
Based on that, the difficult thing is, it
has been for our district.  We did
n't know we were going to be
in this situation back
in 2022.
So, that money
will ultimately benefit a school
wherever the students go.
So, I want to make sure
that the students
and staff are
safe in the building,
that the students know that
if the students know
that something is changing,
then we're going to do that work.
But we didn't know we were going to be
in this situation.
And it's important, in any
case, that students
feel safe,
that everyone is safe,
and that we make those investments.
One second.
If you can come this way, please.
A quick announcement.
If you are recording,
remember that we cannot post
things online that involve students.
So, if you are
capturing students,
please do not post it online.
Another question.
What will happen to
special education teachers?
Yes, I need our
students, our families,
and our staff to know
that at no point
in this process have I
ever said anything other than that
if our educators
and staff want to be
in this district, they will
have their home here.
What's going to happen, and Ali
talked about this,
but I want to be clearer,
we're going to go through a
hiring process, right?
So, it's going to be based
on the plan for that school.
Covington will have a different
staffing plan
than Paredes.
So, it's based on where we are
in our academic path.
But my intention is
that our students
see faces they are
familiar with,
that there are leaders in their schools.
And as these schools
hire more staff,
I want us to start with the staff
who were already working
in these schools.
In terms of our
special education educators,
they are not placed based on enrollment
but on the needs of the students.
So, if Bedicheck teachers
go to a school
that doesn't have that unit
or that support,
then the
special education director
will evaluate and place that
person where they are needed,
because this will happen over
time
as
these students move
through our organization.
So, we want to
meet the needs
of those students
wherever they are.
So, we don't want anyone to leave,
but in terms of
special education staff, it
depends on where
our students go.
(speaking in English)
Something I want to clarify
because there seems to be some confusion.  You've
probably heard
that there will be staff
who won't have a place.
I want to explain
how we are going to close schools,
but the staff will stay on.
Yes. We have 70,000 students.
Nearly 11,000 employees.
And every year, every year,
we hire almost 700 teachers,
educators, and staff.
So what that means
is that instead of having to
go outside of AISD
to hire, what we
're going to do is hire
those who are already in Austin ISD.
That's the way we're going to do it.
So, the total number
of positions will be reduced,
but because of our size
we can protect our educators
and our staff who
want to stay here at AISD.
And I want to be very clear,
we are taking into account
the opinion of our
teachers and our staff.
We know that some educators
live in the south or in the north.
Perhaps they want to have a
different experience,
to teach in a different school.  We
are taking all of that into consideration
before making
plans for staffing.
Students, do we have any
other questions here?
Oh, here, okay, come here.  They
are very brave.
Excellent.
What other options are
available for the school,
and what options are you considering?
What other options are
available for the school
, and what other
things are we
proposing to do, right?
We explored several options
before arriving at this point.
What is your name?
Lincoln?  Okay.
We explored many options before
arriving at this point.
One of the things I want to emphasize
is that we have tons of empty spots
in all the
high schools in South Austin.
And that's because people have
moved out of the area.
So, there aren't enough
sixth, seventh, and eighth grade students.
So, we have Bedicheck in the middle,
we have Covington in the west,
we have Lively and Mendez in the northeast.
So when we think
about moving students, it
's very difficult for a single school to
move its entire school to
another high school.  It wo
n't fit.
So, we need to see how
we can move students
in a way that creates a
balance in South Austin.
So, that's how
we arrived at this solution.
And it really depends on geography,
based on where Bedicheck is located.
Before coming here,
we reduced our expenses from last year
by more than $100 billion.
We reduced staff.  I did
everything I could
before coming to the schools.  It's
something we didn't want to do.
And that's how we arrived at this plan.
And the goal for the future
is to go through this process
and then start Bedicheck again
with a different program
based on what
the community and students need.
That would be the plan for the
future.  Does it make sense?
Excellent question.
What grade are you in?  Seventh?
Hello, my name is Shanda.
I have a seventh-grade student.
My daughter went to Ann Richards
and my son is going to another high school.
My daughter is in special education.
(speaking in English) It's going to
be very difficult
next year with the move.
When they say they have empty places,
they say they have to go and
hire these teachers.
So, I don't understand
why they have to go
and hire these teachers
if they have all these empty places.
Because it's
the teachers who leave
Austin ISD every year
for other school districts,
people who are retiring.
So, that rate of teachers leaving
and staff leaving,
that allows us to
hire every year.
(speaking in English) Have
you taken the time to understand
why they are leaving?
Well, right now we have
97-something percent
of our staffing capacity.
So, you asked me a question
and I'm trying to answer it, right?
Based on the teachers who are leaving,
(speaking in English)
you would have title one schools
that have teachers in their first year.
So, every time a teacher leaves
and a new teacher comes in,
you have to give them an induction,
you have to give them an orientation,
train them so that they have
enough tools
to support the students.
And that takes time.
So, we are
losing a lot of teachers
in our Title One schools.
So, we've really reduced
the number of teachers
who do that, right?  It's about
having a better
school culture and climate.
When I first arrived,
we had to hire
26 directors that year.
This was, this was before
we were here.
When schools are paid,
(speaking in English)
schools are paid
depending on attendance, yes.
So, that student is still there,
the school shouldn't have to
do the budget.
(speaking in English)
So, that's when
we parents have to go
and fight for that funding,
which should be given to the schools, whether
the students are in class or not.
Yes. And for the last two years
that has been our focus.
It has been about increasing the
average daily attendance.
We need to use that
to calculate the funds.
So, let's say
Matias comes to school
and only comes four out
of five days.
So, we
only get funding
for the days I was at school.
But that doesn't mean
the teacher isn't there.  I still have to
pay
the teacher, the principal.
So, are we trying to increase
average daily attendance?
And now we are 1.3%
higher than last year.
It seems like a small number,
but it's actually quite a lot.
So, we are focusing
on chronic absenteeism.
And if you go up one and a half or two percent,
we're talking about 70,
80 million dollars.
(buzz of the crowd)
[Interpreter 2] I
completely agree with you.
So, it's a lot.
Then we wouldn't need to
have this conversation.  It
would have been very useful, and there have
been many things.
And we have to say, there have been many defenses.
So, the state has
not responded well.
And we've had it since last year.
Because if you're not
here in Bedicheck, whoever it is,
then absenteeism in a
low-income neighborhood.
So, the government is
n't going to pay for that.
Then, they can make their lives better.
I agree.
So, it's going to take a lot.
We have a question here.
I have a daughter in seventh grade here.
Then I had other children here.
And it has been a great help
to me to be here.
I think the transition
you are making
is causing all of this.
My daughter is a "transfer" child,
we're not from here.
I have a daughter here.
It's on Bedicheck.
(speaking in English) I
know why they're here, good
programs here at Bedicheck.
The change of zones.
(speaking in English)
Oh, sorry.
What will happen to my
children now that...?
His algebra classes, all of these classes.
So, that's why
we're preparing
for her to go to school.
So, these...
So, these children who are being
sent to these schools.
So, we're ready
to go to university.
How are you going to do that?
We create our programs
based on (indistinctly)
the students
and the programs here are
where the students live.
So, as we move forward,
we're looking at
each of the transitions
and seeing which programs
aren't in Covington.
What programs are not available in
Paredes that are needed
because these students
are going there?
And we need to make sure they have
programs that support them.
The programs are moving.
We need to
support all programs
that will help
students based on leadership
and also based on
community and students.  That's why
we're
doing this with enough time
so that I have enough time
for the students to be successful.
(indistinct)
But we are going to
move to
student-based programs.
(indistinct)
(baby crying)
We are seeing in High School, too,
that students go to a High School
and are seeing what programs are going to be
offered in High School.
Because they thought she was
going to another school.
Then you'll be
able to make those adjustments.
This is all based on
student needs.
And then, we have to
see what programs
you're going to need.
(speaking in English)
I hope the
changes they're talking about will be made.
So the question here
was, when do they do it?
We are still at this time where,
once the voice is made, the vote is made,
we are going to have planning frameworks
to move forward,
but we cannot produce them
until we have the
voices of the students
and the voices of the community
because there may be things that
are on that campus,
that are changing or that we can do here
because I am going to tell you what it is that you
need.
We want this conversation to say,
this is what our
students need,
what we need to hire,
what adjustments we need to make,
and how to train and move forward
with the schools.
So, you're not
going to have this now.
During this time we want to make a plan,
but we don't know exactly what to do.
So, from November 20th,
we're going to move forward, we're going
to put the directors in place.
And then, we're going to make hires
and we'll have the academic programs. It
all depends on the
student needs
and how it's going to be run.  That's why
those
processes and conversations
are so important.  That's why we're
not going to
do it next semester.
We'll have plenty of time.
So, let's go
back here.  A question.
(speaking in English)
In seventh grade.
I have a question.  And my question is:
Why, how?
Why, as a seventh-grade student, ca
n't we end up here?  That
's an excellent question.
Finish eighth grade here.  That's
a great question.
(speaking in English)
I want to answer, but I want to ask, to
answer in a way
that is really analyzed and thought out.
In the state of Texas there is education,
the Texas education agency.
They determine
how they think the
schools are doing
and assign these ratings.  We
all know that our students,
we know that we are much better
than any assessment
or any exam that has been given.
But unfortunately
we are in a state
that has a slightly different approach.
This is the reality we
are facing,
and that I am facing, and
what prevents us from being able to do that is
Bedicheck in the last three years.
Although there has been great growth,
academically we are so close,
but from the state's perspective there have been
three
consecutive years of failing to meet
the responsibility.
That's the word they use.
So, if we don't make a change,
that fourth year...
So, we as
the school district
could lose our ability
to support the 70,000 students.
Here's an example.
We're at the library right now.
We love Austin ISD libraries
and we believe in the love of reading,
not just reading to
prepare for exams.
So, I don't read
much anymore, I love to read
and there are school districts that
no longer have librarians.
Can you believe that?
There are school districts in Texas
that do not have librarians.
We made the decision
with our board
and administration to say,
"We value librarians,
we value our curriculum."
We want to make sure that we have
control
over what you will
learn each year.
It is our responsibility.
But if we don't address the three
years of non-compliance,
we're going to lose control
of making those decisions
for all our students.
So, it's a time of urgency.
Nothing to do with you.
You are doing what you
are doing
and what you are going to do.  It's
really
my role, and with the state, to
find this balance.
So if they had another year
, it could be a fourth year
and that just triggers
those interventions,
but more and more things are going to be done
so that they could even
take it away from us, it's a big pro...
So when we can do it,
we like to try to do that.
(baby crying)
So, right now,
there are two school districts
that are currently doing that, and
the state of Texas has already removed them.
The largest is Houston.
You have heard of Houston, the
Houston school district.
And recently the
Fort Worth school district
is like us.
We are very similar in size.
We are about 70,000 students.
And recently they have been notified
that they are going to hold an
administrators' meeting
with the superintendent
assigned by them,
but these things can
happen and we cannot avoid
a tough decision because I want to ensure
that when you are in High School,
and when your little brother or sister
or these generations of students
after you that come,
they are receiving an education
based on our values ​​in Austin.  They
need to be our values
and we will protect them,
and even if we have to
make tough decisions,
you will all benefit
from being in this community
and not simply being
run by the state.
Great question.
An excellent question.
(speaking in English)
So, if we all include ourselves.
So, that's where we have
teams that help us.
And it's not going to be perfect, because
if you're going to see, based on
(speaking in English)
how each family decides to
approach this, each one.  There will be
divisions,
and we want to reduce the
number of divisions.
At some point there must be
up to five different divisions
because there are more and more groups.
And then, let's say, maybe
your friends are going to Perez,
but you're zoned for
Covington, so we'd say,
if you want to go to Perez, we're going to
automatically approve you.
I want to make sure that
our students,
that you know how hard this is.
And it's very disruptive, and I'm really sorry about that.  That's why
I want to make sure
that during the transition
we will do everything we can
to make this transition as smooth as possible.
And it's never going to be wonderful.
But now that we can do it
, you can
go with your friends,
but not in a way that
everyone goes together
because it's Middle School.  It's going to
be very difficult.  We
can do it in elementary school,
but not in middle school.
Thank you.
We have one more question from a student
and then we could ask another one.
My question.
What grade are you in?  Do
you have any data on our
successful students
at other schools?
Yes, it really has to do with,
all this stuff about it either
working or not working.
So, it really is, it's about
how much time,
energy, and focus we're using.
So, we just do it.
We talked about something, about
doing something in the spring
and saying we made this
decision during "spring break"
and then we hired,
we have a plan between "spring
break" and in the summer.  We're
not going to be successful.  We're
simply going to do it
because what we need
in this plan is time
and conversations with
you, with your community,
with your colleagues and our families,
and then build a
plan that actually works
and test it,
and hire to make sure that it's
really done faithfully.
When it's done right,
those plans are made with
reflection and thought,
and they are being local, the
students (indistinct).
When I've seen it go wrong, it's
when it's a reaction.
When we wait later in the semester,
we make a decision
and don't have time to plan.  I've
seen it, I've seen
that it has been successful,
but only if we plan
and support our
students throughout the process.
So yes, it's both, yes,
we control that.
(speaking in English)
So, we're going to...
If we close...
Then, which schools are they going to go to?
Then, Covington, Paredes and Mendez.
Those are the three schools
that are currently there.
Most of the students are
going to Covington.
And the second group will go to Paredes,
and a smaller group will go to Mendez.
What's your name, Akari?
I am in seventh grade.  I
'm curious.
(speaking in English)
So, how are the
funds for schools made?
It is divided equally.
They have some very good questions.
(applause)
That's how the funds work.
We create the funds based
on students and
student needs.
Let me give you an example.
If you have a
large number of students,
you're going to have more teachers,
you need more
teachers to support the...
We base our programs on that.
If there is a special program at the school
and it does a
dual language program or another program,
we have to make
staff based on that.
So, there are more distributions.
So, (indistinctly)
programs related to UIL,
whether fine arts or sports.
If there are enough students
who have an interest,
especially in High School,
then we have to give them funding.
So, it's really based
on student needs.  We have had
schools
that have a little more support
and we are going to provide more staff,
whether they are instructional coaches,
people who come to help teachers
and simply support the teachers.
So, to tackle
problems (indistinctly),
then, if a line is going to
be based on students
and then goes to the need of students,
then it's not all the same,
but it is based on the
needs of students.
Yes.
(speaking in English)
- [Interpreter 1] As the
school is closing,
well, I would say that's the number of places there are
in all of South Austin.
And what puts pressure on the system is the
state's accountability,
which is what the ratings are.
(speaking in English)
And what if we funded
schools, (applause)
better schools that
are having difficulties
like this one.  We'll do it
, we'll do it right now.
The reality is that it's difficult to
take the next step
because there's no more money.
So if I had
more funds available,
I would do more.
But, since there are so many
empty places throughout the district, I ca
n't do it without
cutting the budget.
So, we're already
doing it, we want to do more,
but I need to have
money to be able to do it.
(speaking in English)
And we could,
we're saving money, but
then we're reversing it.
Are you in seventh grade?  Okay.
(applause)
Hello, I am Miss Mendoza.
I want to say a few positive things.
I know that students are
leaving and teachers too,
but I feel that
some things have been said at this meeting
to clarify things like
geography and responsibility.  These
are the reasons why
Bedicheck has been chosen to close.
But, coming from being in this library
as a student myself to being a teacher,
I feel like I've heard a lot of information,
but something I don't hear enough of
are all the positive things we do,
even academically.
I understand that we have certain
accountability issues
because of the way the state
ranks our schools,
but it's not being acknowledged
that we are a school that carries a stigma
of accountability.
And it's kind of crazy not to hear
all the positive things
about our school,
especially when we
have people from the district
asking us, "Oh,
how did you, how did you manage this?"
So, I mean, I'm
hearing things in the media.
But I believe we don't
receive enough credit
for all the hard work we do.
So, I mean, (applause)
I wanted to say those kinds of positive things.
(applause)
(speaking in English)
That's what makes
this so difficult.
The pressure of the schedule.
When I arrived here, I
believe it was in 2024.
That's when the
2023 accountability came up.
And we were genuinely
trying to create a plan
to work on Bedicheck
and stabilize things.
And there are incredible things
happening
not only in Bedicheck but
throughout the entire school system.
And so, right now it's so
negative at the moment,
but these are excellent schools
and these rankings
are there because someone
is evaluating the schools that way.
And how many schools do we have?
The growth we have seen
in recent years has been incredible.
And yes, we noticed it, that's why
we came to
ask you how you did it.
But at the end of the day,
the state evaluates
things in a certain way.
And we're frustrated that
we're here right now,
but if we don't do something,
long-term students
in Austin ISD
could be affected, and it's going to happen.
If we don't make these decisions, these
things are going to happen.
So, I love our
teachers, our staff,
and we are here
(speaking in English)
because of things that have happened
over the past few decades.
But I love this
school district and something has to change
to protect who we are.
So, I want to make sure I
protect the staff.
I want to make sure that there is
student input
in the process, but yes,
things are difficult.
And there are incredible things
happening here.
(speaking in English)
And one of the questions
the students asked
was about one who played volleyball.
There are three teams here.
So,
what are we going to do about the
Bedicheck and Covington teams?
They are different teams.
(speaking in English)
Yes, there are already three teams here.
So how are we going to
get all that equipment
to a single school?
(speaking in English)
We have three people,
sorry, who are waiting
to ask questions.
But I want to answer
that question too.
We're going back to it.  Yes.
Hello, my name is Selena Castañeda.  I
have six daughters, all at AISD.
Six?
Yes, Blazier, Crockett
and three of my daughters have
been here in Bedicheck.
(speaking in English)
And there are many positive things,
as they were saying.
My eldest daughter finished eighth grade,
and I mean, she was first,
but she was one of the
top students
with the highest average.
He was in the choir all
three years he's been here.
In orchestra.
And she went to the regional competition
and both opportunities were given to her
because they were here
building that choir program,
the orchestra with the Miss Stewarts,
who used part of their summer to
train the students.  He
also represented the volleyball team,
the basketball team,
the track and field team, and he
plays chess.
And as I said, he finished eighth,
in the highest percentage.
With one of the highest averages,
everything he did here was
thanks to those programs.  I would
n't have had those opportunities
if it weren't for the program
that only Bedicheck offers.
And I know you said you
can move those plans.
There are plans to move those programs,
and I'll get to that in a moment.
But I also want to say
that those opportunities would
not have been possible without teachers
like Miss Ramos, Mr. Noonan,
Mr. Jackson, and Miss Stewart.
I want to make sure I don't forget
any of these teachers.
(speaking in English)
She has not stopped training
and supporting the
student athletes she has.
And there is so much uncertainty
for these teachers
and coaches
who are still giving 100%
to the students.
Miss Mijares, Miss Bryant,
staff like Miss Atkinson,
Miss Hartman, Miss Smith.
Last year, my daughter didn't have it,
there were so many things in her schedule,
but she still
wanted to participate in her choir
and get her Spanish credits.
And Miss Hartman and Miss
Atkinson made that possible.
And that's what Bedicheck is, it
gives these children opportunities.
If they take away Bedicheck,
they are taking away those opportunities.  He
's currently at Crockett and is doing excellently
as a freshman.
She's in an advanced math class,
and in her class, the only
other freshman girl
in that class is from Bedicheck,
in Crockett's advanced math class.
Because no other school
is offering that opportunity.
And she's thriving there,
she's doing excellently
in all her classes.
And that's part of the structure
that Bedicheck has.
Sports.
She had those opportunities
to learn sports,
to play sports, to get straight A's
for the size of Bedicheck.
I know it's not
as big a school as Covington
or Paredes,
but because of the size of the school,
she had those opportunities.
And now, as I said, he's also
in the choir over there.
And as a ninth-grade student,
she is the only student in that
class who can read music.
And that's because of the education they received
here
in the programs they
had here in Bedicheck.
So, please excuse me for talking so much.  I
also have an
eighth-grade student here;
she's a student representative.
(speaking in English)
She is the president
and also part of the student council.  It
represents volleyball,
basketball, and athletics.
And meanwhile, she continues to
have pure A's at three years
in advanced academic programs.
And he's going to finish this year
with those two
advanced math credits.  It
will have IPC credit,
which I think is also
an excellent opportunity
to get into Crockett and
not have to worry
about the schedule and the
credits you have to complete.
Yes. Also
, I have a
sixth-grade student
in the same programs.
So, how long will it take for
that program to start operating?
And the other thing is, the location.
Bedichek has one of
the best locations,
no matter which direction you're coming from.
I can come from any direction.
I can get here on time every day.
They have perfect attendance
because this school
operates in that way.
And
all of that will have to be taken into consideration
if the school is changed, right?
If Bedichek closes.
Thank you.
(applause) Do
you want to say something about that?
No, super impressed,
but yes, very impressed.
I have two daughters.  I ca
n't imagine having six.
I believe that what
your students are experiencing
is what we want for Austin ISD.
I would say that we are in
a very
difficult situation.
There are many decisions being made
that are really trying
to reduce the pressure
and stress on the system.
The budget, the change at the federal level.
There are many, there aren't many options.
The only option would be to
wait and see what happens.
But that's not something
I'm willing to do.
So, the way I process this
is if I recognize that it's
something that has to happen,
how can I support the students?
The programs
that failed did so
because they were not
properly planned, and
the necessary resources were not allocated.
So, for me, I don't
have many options.  It
really is, closure is the
only way to achieve this.
(speaking in English)
But I appreciate your feedback
and what we're trying to do
is figure out how to do this thoughtfully.
And because we want their daughters to have
everything they've had in Bedichek,
but we have to adjust
and do what's best for the whole city.
- [Interpreter 2] My name is Silvia Peña.
I'm here because...
and to do what's best for the whole city.
If they are with the grades.
They knew that the grades were failing
,
and that's why they didn't offer
summer school programs.
If they didn't address the summer problems, that's why
we're in this situation where
our schools are closing.
We have a lot of support,
we have very good academic classes.
And if it weren't for Mrs.
Atkins and tutoring and ROTC,
not every school would have ROTC.
And my child needed the discipline,
and so it has helped him
to be a better person.
So, there are many opportunities
here for children.
But then, why didn't they do it?
Why didn't they go in and say something?  They
already failed once
because they didn't make an effort to get
the children to
come to school.
How they did it (indistinct).
What I heard was that there were
three schools
that offered to see them.  We would
n't be in this position
if you had offered.
They say you
care about the students,
and the students come and the
attendance is very good here.
So, it's about the money
and not the children.
And that's not right.
(applause)
That's not correct.
You said it was about the children,
but they're not being offered
summer programs.
I want to be clear.  We
are talking about 22-23, 23-24, 24-25.
What we (indistinctly)
then see,
we talk about stability
and how the system looks.
Then,
leadership changes occurred,
which caused instability
throughout Austin ISD.
So, I am committed
and remain committed
to providing the support
that students need.
So, I need to understand
what each
school community needs,
how we can support them,
and then move forward.
And this is something, a challenge,
is that we have to make those decisions
and we will probably
deliver results,
(speaking in English)
but we are going to do it in a
way that is responsible.
So, what we want, and are
fortunate enough to be able to do,
is to do it in a sustainable way.
So, whoever is in charge
in the following years
can continue it if
we back down now.
But we've had
problems with these schools.
I also want to say something.
(speaking in English)
So,
you asked why we didn't
have summer schools.
We had to compromise
because we don't have enough
money to make them.
So when we talk about money, it's
to spend our money
where there were going to be students.
And then, the (indistinct) districts.
So if our schools
don't use our programs, that's
money being wasted.
So, that's why
we're in this process
because of the amount of money.
And most of the money we're going to get
back is going
to go to our schools again.
But it's not like the district
keeps that money.
We want to use the money to
put it into schools.
When it comes to education,
some parents
have no problem
paying for their children and their education,
schools, insurance, tutoring,
anything the
students need
to make them successful academically.
Yes, and I think...
Let's be honest, not
all students
have the same needs.
I think we can see that this is
the correct way to operate.
So, we have,
we must have more resources
to be able to continue supporting the children.
We can see hiring, placements.
There are some decisions that
other superintendents
could have made about
how many students to have,
how many instructional coaches,
how many teachers for certain grades,
so we can lower it even further.
So, we've used a lot of
energy to try to figure out
what the problem is that we
have to face
in each school.
But let me tell you,
all the changes the district
is making are necessary.
(speaking in English)
So, if we're going to talk,
we need to find the money
to use the
resources that are needed.  It's
not just about identifying
a specific school or something, but it's
really a function of the
entire system,
trying to find open spaces
and see that resources
can go to teachers,
to students, to programs.  I
don't have the skill or the funds.
(speaking in English)
It's going to be worse because you're going to
send all these schools
to different schools.
(speaking in English)
Yes, no, we already saw all that.
We're going to plan the staffing for all of these.
Therefore, we would never offer
something we couldn't deliver.
(speaking in English)
So, and really the composition
of the students and
teachers is not going to change.
And we have a transformation plan
to ensure they have
the necessary teachers.
We're going to ask a question
that this student has
been waiting to ask for a while.
(speaking in English)
And what about transportation?
And with our policy now,
(speaking in English)
if you're more than two miles away,
you're going to have automatic transportation.
(speaking in English)
So, it might be, I don't know,
an area like William Cannon's or something.
A larger area.
That's the policy.
So, how are we going to operate now,
and now we're going to have
Covington and Paredes.
So, if there's any
gap in transportation, we're going
to cover it; we're going to
use the two-mile radius.
And if they go to High School,
depending on how big it is
and how big the
transportation systems are, we'll
work it out accordingly.
Rosabela.
(speaking in English)
(applause)
The interpreter didn't understand this.  I'm
listening.  It's very difficult.
I want to make sure our students
stay in Austin ISD,
and that's why we're
doing all of this
and having a family meeting.
But so that we can understand each other
and know how to best support them.
(speaking in English)
And we have a couple
more questions, three more.
(speaking in English)
I have an eighth-grade child
and I have another one I'm thinking about,
happy to attend
Bedichek soon.
But obviously they're going to close the schools.
(speaking in English)
So, my main question is:
Considering that in the
last year taxpayers
have paid so many millions of dollars.
And for the master plan like
other school districts
in the state of Texas,
and simultaneously the state has
a surplus of 24 billion dollars,
how is it not possible that they
distribute money to us
to help with this
deficit that we have here?
(applause)
Dylan, what you're describing
(speaking in English)
is what hasn't been done
for the last few years.
So, the recapture,
we seized 714 million
a few weeks ago
and another amount about two
weeks ago.  Yes, you are correct.
The money is collected, it
goes to the state, and the state
redistributes it.  Not everything.  They
sustain themselves with a large part of it.
The problem is that we've
fought and fought and fought,
and we only have a couple of
legislators in Central Texas
and just as many in the rest of the
state.
So, others
benefit from the recapture.
So, they're not going to vote,
to do it in a different way.
That's the truth, it's the truth.
That's how
things are done in the state.
In the legislature, you
need to have a majority
and you have to support it.
So, we've been
arguing and arguing and arguing
about this topic.
We filed a lawsuit in 2017, we
challenged him, we challenged him
in 2019, and then we carried on.
But it's not going to change, it's
simply not going to change.
So, our people
changed, we said.
Very well, I understand that we won't be able to
receive it because of the power it has.
So, we simply have more
public education funding.
Let's do that.
(speaking in English)
Let's see how to divide
the millions of dollars
in the school system.
(speaking in English)
And we decided to
spend it on the teachers.
(speaking in English)
And there was a little
movement in the
$20 million structure, then.  It was
used for
certain programs.
And we finished, seeing how to combine,
how to spend the dollars.
So, in the end,
there was an increase of around
10 million dollars.
The teachers received a raise,
which is wonderful
because we needed that.
And that's the
biggest problem we're stopping.
Including the federal government.
This is where the
Title 1, Title 2,
Title 3, and Title 4 funds
that come from the government are located.
(speaking in English)
So, at the beginning of the year,
he sent a letter to the
families saying that
the source of funds that
was to pay the salaries
was closing and I am not in a position
because I don't have the resources
to charge them once.
So, they really impacted
our balance sheet.
We need individual support
with all the things we truly believe in.
And the reality is that I'm
just trying to
get to a place where we don't have to
be dependent on those kinds of funds.
So, I'm going to keep fighting,
but unfortunately Austin
(indistinct) we should have.
And so, in order to
have our funds,
we need between $1100
and $1300 per student.
And the legislature wanted to offer that,
but it's nothing close
to what it actually costs to
support a student.
My name is Maria.
(speaking in English)
I have been a
transfer mom for seven years.
I have a daughter who is in seventh grade.  He
is very sad.
I told him it was time to leave.
I'm really going to leave Austin.  I do
n't have a question.
(speaking in English)
Mr. Segura, you have a very difficult task ahead of you.
So, because I have an
older daughter, and (indistinctly)
You have it very hard.
But I see this as
a game of Monopoly.  So
good luck.
I think putting
children in the same school
is a very bad idea,
and it's happening because we also have
Langford from Palm.
My daughter needs to get up
at six in the morning
because she has to be picked up
by a bus at 6:40.
And the parents have to...
...just take them to school
and before the parents of...
and they're not allowed to play in the
playground,
but they're not allowed to play
because they're not in that school.
And then we have to
build a playground
so our children can go and play.
So, it's very difficult to be
able to go to a gym.  They
need to build another gym
and that's where they have their sports classes.
(speaking in English)
And I've been trying this
since, how long ago.
And I've been through this whole transition,
and I live just a few
minutes' walk away.
(speaking in English)
So, I've been
dealing with my daughter
and I've had to do everything.
So, she's very sad about this.
I know I can get through it with the plan.  We're
no longer going to see Austin
ISD as an option.
Charter School maybe.
My opinion is that,
(speaking in English) I don't
know, I have no idea what
you're going to do.
But I imagine
that combining
two schools into one is no longer an option.
Because, like her,
because the program is not
the same as she says.
So, choose what you
have in one house and go to another,
you'll be the visitor.
And then the district is going to do that.
So, I think that's a problem.
(speaking in English)
- [Interpreter 2] We don't
want anyone to feel like they're
a visitor, do we?,
when we're putting the schools together.
Yes, I appreciate that.  It
's difficult.
We have been here for 144 years.
The district has evolved, it has changed.
And there have been many things
that probably aren't great.
But we cannot continue to be
the district we have been.
Because we have families in
other parts of the city
who don't have the resources.
And I don't have the resources for them.
So, it's something very complex.  I
have 70,000 students in 116 schools.
Not just one, one, one, right?
So, these are our students, these are
our families.
And I love this district and I love this city.
When we are thinking
about combining schools,
we are building teams
that are called bridge teams.
And we started that when we were
modernizing schools
where we are very proactive,
we talked about who should be
at the discussion table,
who knows the history of the schools,
how to bring the PTAs together,
how they are going to do the programs.
All that support.
That's what's going to happen in this case.
So, we have the
frames for those teams.
We are tracking different
data with accuracy.
So, if there's anything that's needed,
we can address it immediately.
Then, we can succeed.
I am very saddened by
what is happening now,
and also, thank you for
sharing your comment.
Okay, this is going to be
our last question.
Hello, my name is Stephanie,
I have a child in special education.
My question is,
why have this meeting
to express our concerns
if I feel the decision has already been made
without considering
our students and parents?
Why do all this?
That's my question.
Yes.
(speaking in English)
We started this process in February or March
of this year, right?
We identified five big things we
were trying to fix.
All the
responsibility ratings
for three consecutive years were released.
And we were going through this process
and that would have been different
if we had known that we were going to be
here in November.
So, we have a plan.  We've been
refining that plan,
but there are... There
aren't many big parts
that can be changed
without putting
our board
and administration at risk.
So,
(speaking in English)
one thing we agreed on
is that we need to reduce
the budget deficit.
If we don't reduce the
number of empty places,
that won't be achieved.
So, if we don't close some schools,
we'll be here next year
having the same conversation.
We're going to have zero time to plan
because the district is going to be
in a terrible situation.
So, because there are two things, right?
Responsibility and
also funding.
So, I don't want to
delay this process any further.
(speaking in English)
I prefer to be clear
about what we're going to have to do.
And I know the community wants what's best
for all our students
and to proceed with minimal disruption,
but give the
community time to plan.
So, that's why we're
doing it this way.
Yes, I'm listening to feedback.
I am not the one who ultimately makes the decision;
it is the board of directors.
But I want us to be
able to contribute to the elements
of the plan by thinking it through.
I have a quick question.
Are you saying that this is
based on certain categories
and if you don't meet those criteria,
the state will still treat you the
same way?
These five areas:
transfer rules,
responsibility, and
program changes.
Those are our goals
for changing the entire system.
What I can tell you is that I do
n't know if we'll ever be
able to align all
the referral patterns
here in Austin.
Thinking about some of the schools,
there are schools like Covington
that go to Crockett.
(speaking in English) We
probably couldn't achieve that
and fully align all
referral patterns
so that all
students pass together.
Yes.
They're going to read all the
details of our plan.
If the state is
trying to take control,
of course not.
I would like to move away...
Yes, the further we move away
from our goals in the plan,
the more risk we face from
the state.
The more risk we will have to manage
in terms of budget.
What I don't want is to
be a school district
that suddenly has all these things,
is facing all these things,
and the state says, "Well,
we're going to do this.
These teachers are out,
these schools are closing,"
and they make all the decisions.
That's what's going to happen
because they're saying,
"You should have done this
before because you didn't make
these decisions earlier."
So, what I want is for the way
we're doing it to
be more
thoughtful, more considered.  It will
be for the good of the students.
So, if they take
control of our schools,
they're going to make all the decisions.
So what I'm saying is, we're
not going to get to that point.
That helps answer your question.  Yes.
So, I think some of us
might stay a little longer
to continue the conversation.
But I'll quickly review the
schedule.
(speaking in English)
These are important dates that are coming up.
And when will the
next conversation take place?
So, these conversations we
're having with the community
will also include
comment cards.
(speaking in English)
That on Friday we made a new card.
Make sure you use it, make sure you
use the new card.
And this Thursday is already November 6th.
So, the board
will vote on the
final plan on November 20.
So, thanks to the
students who are graduating.
And again, some of
us can stay
if you have any further questions.
(applause)